hi everyone it's sarah with registered
nurse orient calm and in this video
we're going to check the patellar deep
tendon reflex so let me show you how
that is done okay to check the patellar
reflex this is going to be looking at l2
to l4 and to find the tendon what you
want to do is locate the kneecap and
then go just a little bit right below it
and the best way is to have the patient
extend the leg out and then that tendon
will pop out and that is where you're
gonna go okay after locating the tendon
put your hand behind the knee just to
support it have them relaxed and the
tendon is right here and what you're
gonna do is you're just going to tap
briskly and what we're looking for is
this lower leg to extend outward so here
we go and we've got a response there and
one more time ain't got a really good
response there okay so that is how you
check that deep tendon reflex now check
out my other videos on how to check the
other for deep tendon reflexes and
consider subscribing to this YouTube
channel